Oh where'd we go hey there oh there we
are
oh we're live Oh we're live all right
let me uh welcome you one second here
all right hello Becky hello how are you
doing yes John says he sees I dressed up
for this one
yes I'm I'm coordinating colors for this
one we have a very special hot breath
live today hot brethren and sistren I'm
thinking we may change its name to
comedians on skype talking comedy
I think we're this is gonna be our
comedians in cars getting coffee but
today's guest is a hot breath alum this
guy has made countless TV appearances
he's toured around the world he is
absolutely hilarious and he has one of
my personal favorite hot breathless ODEs
we recorded up in his hotel room so go
check that on YouTube if you haven't
heard it don't worry hotel room made it
sound more salacious than it is but you
hear his giggle ladies and gentlemen hot
brother and sister and welcome to hot
breath live the one and only jacob willy
everyone welcome Jacob hello thanks for
having me good to see you it's so good
to see you too my friend Howard how are
you doing in these current times that's
the most applause anyone's ever given me
including black shows with we'll do it
again would make you feel at home yeah
whole crowd they say my name and no one
it's only one person clapping even then
I'm glad we're starting us off on a
confident note here Jacob yep yeah like
I have a joke and my stand-up about this
show I did once where like only one
person was in the audience and it's kind
of making fun of how sad that was but
now that would actually be like the
biggest crowd that I've had this month
that would be a big sold-out audience
with the current situation right yeah
what how has how has corona virus like
affected your standup how many gigs did
you have canceled like what it what has
been your experience with it yeah it's
been pretty tough a lot of my comedian
friends were telling me out there all
their shows were canceled and it was
like I don't have any shows either but
it's just cuz no one quick to me he's on
a roll right now
unfortunately yeah it's been frustrated
it's kind of yeah every part of my life
so yeah just trying to figure out what
to do next I might have to start like a
webcam show where people took me to keep
my clothes on or something did you is
that a written material was that
prepared did you write that for the show
this is all just off the top of the some
of this I might have thought about a
webcam show we have to keep all my
clothes that's that's a good one Thanks
you're gonna sit as a meme it was gonna
steal that make it a mean some time yeah
I may have to uh yeah that's true now
that I said it after tweeter quickly
took the timestamp things how many gigs
did you actually have canceled cuz like
I mean me personally I had up through
April was cancelled for me so I pretty
much had two months and it's gonna be
more it's looking like but what about
you
yeah I mean I had this thing in June I
was super excited about that guy
cancelled and then some college gigs and
I've been talking to someone about doing
cruise ships that's definitely off the
table now and I had actually just done
this showcase in Denver to kind of look
like a whole college to her at the the
NACA National Convention so I was really
excited about that and then this kind of
put a halt on that whole process so yeah
so it's kind of every everything I've
had has been canceled it was just kind
of scary so yeah just kind of trying to
figure out how to do things tell jokes
online and things like that for the time
being yeah that's what we just had a
Mike cannon are you familiar with Mike
cannon oh yeah yeah his new special is
great and yeah I see him a lot in New
York or before all of this obviously
yeah right yes yeah he um he was on here
Tuesday and he was talking about how
he's been treating this time is just
yeah creating a bunch of content and
trying to just get as much of himself
out there as possible what what have you
been doing in that realm yeah that's a
good point yeah I've been kind of just
trying to keep up routines we're all
right jokes for like an hour a day and
things like that I've been tweeting out
a lot of those and I've been doing
comedy every day in some form online
like usually running jokes past like a
few other comedians and things like that
I tried doing a show on zoom' where
people could just do it pay what you
wished amount to watch the show Overman
moment and things like that
and unfortunately the first one was kind
of rough because like I just I put the
link out on my social media so I guess
this happens a lot on zoom' or like
anyone can see it and like a random
person came in and like started screen
sharing and like my parents were
watching and they put like four in on
the screen which I'm pretty sure my
parents had never even seen Morton
before because they're very wholesome
and as far as I know I hadn't seen it
either so and the born that it showed
was like also like really messed up
stuff it was almost like they saw my
browsing history or something just but
but no that was that was pretty
disturbing I said I just had to like
kick some people out and then and then
there was like some background noise
when the audio was on like some people I
found out later as my mom was like
walking through a yard and there were
birds and so I was telling jokes and
they just hear like bird noises so I
just had to like mute everyone and then
I was just like I like people were
watching but I couldn't hear if they
were laughing so it was like it was like
doing the stand-up I guess like if you
were blindfolded and had earplugs and
and just because I couldn't see any ones
but you know videos you're on a no sound
was on so I'm like just delivering the
jokes people are watching them but I
have no idea what their responses which
is like with cotton with music that
might work but with comedy it's like you
kind of rely on like knowing whether
people are reacting to it so it was kind
of weird but I'm gonna try to get it
maybe bet the audience a little more and
hopefully do more things like that so
we'll see so you couldn't see or hear
the audience you're just talking to your
screen yeah and there's the option to
see and hear them but then once I heard
the bird noise it like someone was
outside that can kind of really distract
I mean it's like if you're doing a
comedy show if you could imagine you
just suddenly heard like nature sounds
while you were trying to like set up
jokes and so I just had to like I just
ended up like muting everyone and so it
was almost like it felt like a rehearsal
for a stand-up show even though a bunch
of people were watching I was just like
saying my jokes into a point and people
later would message me and they're like
oh we were laughing a lot and all this
stuff but it's like weird to not know
that in the moment you know I did you do
you set up you said a venmo connected to
it how did you do the payment part um
yeah I the first one was kind of
experimental so I just kind of put that
out there as like my even my handle was
like it was like mr Jacob Williams are
just the same as like my Twitter and
Instagram and stuff so I just mentioned
that there was like an option to donate
since I am NOT doing any actual live
shows because they all got canceled so
so some people that did that and it was
really nice but um but yeah I really
just wanted to test out that form
so I might I might try to do it again
but with a little more screening of the
audience just to make sure there's not
any more crazy hackers or hecklers or
whatever I know I have you've never been
heckled with porn before that sounds
like a new one for us comedians right
yeah I mean I don't even know what the
equivalent would be like if someone
somehow like got like a projector and a
screen and just started like showing for
and while you were onstage and your
parents are thought it's an economy club
and it was crazy like that would be a
lot of work in person to light you'd
have to go to the tech booth and like
right ring like one of those like hard
drive things to plug in or something you
have to coordinate it with the DJ it
would be like a music cue the whole Neil
right yeah I think cuz it's online like
there's so much anonymity so people can
just do things like that that I'm sure
that I'd never try anything like that in
person because you would see them and be
like that's not cool but online somehow
I guess some people think that's funny I
don't know it was her what was the porn
by the way you said it was graceful yeah
I was kind of joking it was it was
pretty I think it was like pretty
vanilla superb porn you know but there
was like some penetration and pretty
crappy not really what you want your
parents to watch when they're tuning
getting to see to tell jokes you know
did anyone pay beside your parents did
you actually get some donations my
parents actually didn't hey wait oh I
thought it was interesting I was like
okay they they that's how much they
value my stand-up is zero but but some
other people did so it wasn't it wasn't
much but overall because it was the
first one it was very last minute I kind
of tweeted it out like maybe an hour or
less before I started but a few people
did contribute and I really appreciated
that so it definitely meant a lot to me
because it was kind of the only thing I
couldn't pay this one so it's kind of
nice nice little something it was nice
to see that they appreciated it and but
yeah my parents yeah sometimes when I
talk to them they'll be like oh we
really liked your friends just got and
social medias like to my foreheads too
yeah
I'm like posting
stuff like did you like a name and my
dad's like I don't really remember it
and like okay I'm glad but do you get
residuals from like wild and out you
know I have gotten those occasionally
and it's not something I necessarily I
wouldn't normally yeah rely on it or
anything because it sometimes it's very
small a lot of times it's just really
small amounts I don't know if it was
from wild up but I've gotten ones for
instance from like cold there or Comedy
Central that were sometimes like as
little as like one penny or two penny
yeah like they literally mail me a check
with the amount of one cent and it's
like a full check and postage and I'm
like I mean you know they there's I
don't know this cost so much more to
mail it then like the amount on it and I
still I I still deposit uh but yeah so
it's really can be a hit or miss but but
yeah a couple of times I have gotten
some residuals but now yeah it's just
kind of usually a small amount like that
so I'm just trying to got what to do
I've heard I think with comedy albums it
helps to have those maybe so I'm hoping
I get one of those out soon I recorded
it a while ago and I want to release
that as maybe a special and an album so
I have someone actually now video
editing like the album I did with the
album audio and I'm really excited about
that because it has like maybe five or
six different camera angles that it cuts
around oh great
yeah I'm every last time we saw each
other here in Atlanta you said you're
about to record your album but I didn't
realize also gonna be a special yeah
yeah I'm kind of self producing it as a
special as well and I have been
procrastinating a lot because I really
wanted to make sure everything sounded
how I wanted so like I cut out some of
like the UM xited in the live show and
things like that but overall yeah now
it's like kind of where I want it and
I'm really proud of like all the
material and everything that's kind of
like the greatest hits of everything
I've been working on in the last 12
years so so it's new or some of its
older but it's all my
favorite jokes and so I'm excited to
like actually have people see like a
full hour of my stand-up at some point
so I'll probably it may be I'll be
telling that online soon or something
once it's finally edited by but yeah the
guy who did it is great and has worked
in like TV filming and editing and stuff
so I'm really excited for people to see
that hopefully in the near future oh
yeah I'm excited to see that too man
and the album yeah should be out soon as
well and so that'll be on streaming
services and things like that and we're
kind of having an artist design the
cover now so so yeah I'm excited yeah
for all that to come out soon hopefully
well this this is an interesting this
can actually tie into the first question
we have and first Dennis Dennis to Lee
says it could have been worse it could
have been a video of your parents
getting busy so I guess there's always a
silver lining there maybe my parents
[Laughter]
wasn't your parents either cuz if it
didn't show their faces that's a good
point yeah it was just a screen sharing
thing they they really like to prank me
I guess maybe mm-hmm oh and um Lauren
Lauren says she saw Jacob last month and
he was great very excited for the
special oh thank you Lauren we're which
it was that incase touch can she told me
it would show yeah for sure yeah yeah
this is live so they'll be able to
interact back and forth so and if I want
to see it live I think I have to be is
it in the Facebook app or yeah it's in
it's in the hot breath comedy Network
Facebook group okay so yeah if you if
you get on Facebook you can see us in
there live but I believe Lauren actually
saw you post about this on your
Instagram and then show it she joined
the group after that so the Jake oh okay
Jacob fans are out there so yeah I will
say in terms of the last thing I don't
think it could have been my parents
because even though my parents had me
biologically they're so nerdy I'm pretty
sure they're both still virgins anyway
that's the last thing I'll say
hold on let me get this punch line and
let me couch this tag in really quick I
don't know why anybody would probably
try to move on when someone brings up
their parents having sex I have a funny
tag for it I like to really stay on that
topic as long as possible
oh um Lauren says she was with Andrea
Allen at two boots or too boots oh yeah
yeah that was a really fun show I did
that maybe a couple weeks ago there was
this pizza place called two booths in
Williamsburg Brooklyn and um and it was
great it was like I sold out so I mean
it was like rows and rows of people just
packed in there so yeah one of the most
fun shows I've done in a while so I'm
really glad she in one of the last shows
he'll do for a while I guess
unfortunately for Jasmine yeah oh that's
great well you got a fan in Lauren
thanks Lauren if you have a question for
Jacob please comment with it well get it
answered dennis actually asked have you
ever tried to turn one of your bits into
a sketch
have i ever tried to turn one of my bits
into a sketch that's a good question I
do like sketch comedy as well and I have
I actually have written out like scripts
of based on my my bits where I kind of
tried to turn them into sketches I
haven't filmed a lot of that but I did
take all of the sketch writing classes
and improv classes at UCB so I've
written a lot of sketches that kind of
were separate from my stand-up material
and I feel like that's something
eventually if all of this if we're able
to interact with each other in person
again as a society I'd like to maybe
film more of those and try to get those
out there in some way because yeah some
of those sketches are written I'm super
proud of but a lot of times I my brain
kind of like works differently it feels
like different muscles for me sometimes
with I think with my stand-up I
a lot of times gravitate towards just
like either talking about experiences
I've had her doing like one-liners and
different short form jokes whereas with
sketches I kind of tried to embrace
their style of like focusing on a like I
guess what the UCB calls the game and
like having an unusual thing that you
can like kind of repeat over and over
and like heighten the joke with
different moves and kind of left turns
but it's kind of more focused on like
one emotion the whole time or one
bizarre thing that you can keep like
riffing on so yes I guess in that says
it's I don't know
I'd like to yeah I'd like to put more
sketches out there and stuff whether
it's similar to my stand-up or some of
the other ones I've worked on that are
kind of their own things so um yeah so
hopefully I'll figure out a way to do
that in this situation or just maybe do
it in the future once we can actually
film things that are a little more
complicated than everything so yeah I'd
love to try more things like that yeah
cuz you would see comics now they may
have like a special out but then they'll
even do like an animated version of
whatever it is they're talking about
like people are always looking for
different ways to repurpose their
material yeah that's a good point even
like it seems like the big trend right
now is that you record a bit put a
catchy headline at the top and then put
subtitles underneath it and it seems
like everyone's just pouring a bunch of
like content out with that template in
mind but I feel like there's got to be
other ways yeah that's a good point I'd
like to put out more things like that
and I do have now yeah I guess I can our
recorded material that I might start
doing that with soon but um
yeah it's it's so hard to keep up and I
think in a good way it's like I think
it's so cool that so many comedians are
putting out good stuff with between bits
and sketches and everything and yeah I
know like for me too sometimes I get
kind of intimidated by that in terms of
like stepping out of my comfort zone I
mean I've done like stand-up and stuff
but now I'm inspired to see people like
trying out so many other things like you
know like that you're doing this podcast
and things like that even that I haven't
like started my own podcast or anything
so it's cool to see people trying all
these new avenues and all the various
ways of being funny you know yeah and
I'm sure you're not alone in that
intimidation I mean we all have can have
self-doubt and feel like oh that's good
for them but I could never type deal I
mean what is that what is that
self-doubt and how do you overcome it
because from from comics like us
listening and me watching you it's like
oh that guy that guy's been on Colbert
he's been on wild and out he's been on
America's Got Talent he's Comedy Central
like this this guy's got it figured out
but yet you still have that self-doubt
of like how like Who am I to think that
way how do you overcome those sort of
hurdles yeah I think for me I get yeah I
try to push myself to go outside of my
comfort zone but a bi is funny how like
even yeah having done stand-up on TV a
puncher doing wild and out and improv
stuff on TV like now that I've done it
I'm like oh yeah of course I was able to
do that but then looking into things I
haven't done that I know would I think
would be a lot of fun I get like I think
cuz I do enjoy the creative stuff so
much of just making jokes or things like
that it makes me feel like oh no and now
I'm gonna have to like figure out how to
edit podcasts or put them online or like
I think that for me like the more
technical things are like the biggest
hurdle for me so like that's kind of
like something where I just have to
embrace the challenges more I guess and
kind of just go with it because I think
naturally I have a lot of anxiety in
general about everything that can go
wrong so sometimes I forget like how
scary stand-up was when I first started
doing it because now it's like okay now
I'm used to that but then when I had
that for a new thing I have to remind
myself like oh I can't just like stay
and the things I'm used to like you
still I think it's always
to push yourself to new things I'm glad
at least I've been able to get out of my
comfort zone a bit with improv and
stand-up and stuff but I would like to
go much further in terms of doing more
sketches and doing more podcast type
things and things like that so yeah I
think it's something where you you kind
of have to like I think we all have to
do that where we just push ourselves
into that stuff even when it's scary and
it's definitely I'm mostly just giving
advice to myself at this point
oh good so it's good self-talk yeah and
especially now with like so many live
shows shutdown and stuff yeah now it's
like it's so important to try all these
new things so I'm excited to see what
everyone's doing and kind of try to
explore that as well and see what
happens I guess yeah how do you overcome
anxiety what have you found to be most
useful um that's a good question I feel
like yeah I have a lot of anxiety in
general but things that have helped me
lately are kind of just committing to
like doing habits that things I want to
do even if I feel anxious about it and I
feel like just I've been like at least
during the quarantine I've kind of
started habits of like working out every
day which I think blows off a lot of
stress and then writing jokes for an
hour a day I think like gets rid of some
of my anxiety of like oh I'm not like
doing enough because in general yeah a
lot of times whatever I'm doing I'm like
oh I'm what if I'm missing out and
something else or whatever and so I
think a lot of it just comes down to
like just trying to like look at all the
things that I'm grateful for and just
trying to like enjoy whatever choice I
do make and making the most out of it
and then realizing I can you know if
there's something else I want to try and
I can try that next so I think just yeah
it kind of trying to start new habits
with small things where like if I'm
trying to read more just like reading
like a paragraph and then trying to
celebrate that and so then you you're
you have like a positive emotion with it
and it's not like a chore so then you
can kind of like once you're in that
frame of mind then you're like oh this
is why then you might just keep doing
whatever the new hobby is like reading
per hour
or whatever but but I think getting
started is the hardest part so yeah I'm
just I can be like pretty self-critical
in general so it just I'm kind of just
trying to learn how to do those things
where it's more like self-care and
things like that and it's funny because
that actually like makes me more
productive even though in the moment I'm
like I'm not working hard enough or
whatever but when I'm in that positive
state of mind or rewarding myself for
doing little things then it just makes
me want to do that more and keep
pursuing it in writing where or whatever
it is so yes love that small the big
victory for a small like accomplishment
I'll I'll leave it for writing if I
write the date at the top of the page
I'm like oh cool I wrote today
everything else from here on out is just
extra credit you know I really set a low
bar and that helps me to really jump
over it that's great yeah yeah there was
something I heard about I think there's
a book called like tiny habits or
something that huh I kind of heard that
strategy from just recently but yeah I
think that's a really good way to go for
sure are you riding an hour a day and
people keep keep commenting with your
questions will will keep weaving those
in here but I do want to get into like a
big topic on here is writing and you
saying that you're consistently writing
for an hour a day how did you work up to
that habit and also what does your
writing look like um yeah that's another
one that yeah I guess that's an example
of something I tried that is I guess a
little bit of a bigger stuff for me but
basically I was kind of just frustrated
that I felt like I wasn't writing enough
because whenever I'd sit down to write
I'd get distracted and think like oh
maybe I should be sitting this email
instead of doing this other thing and
then I'd end up like procrastinating it
and I felt like I wasn't really
developing as much material as I wanted
but that kind of was partly an idea of
my therapist I didn't like doing therapy
has been super helpful and I'm really
lucky to have a therapist who I found
who's affordable and works with
comedians and it's been really great but
um right but basically but yeah
kind of one of his ideas of like since I
was stressed out about not writing
enough to kind of just have a goal in
mind like that and so far I think I've
done it for I guess like maybe three
weeks in a row now whoa
everyday writing and so yeah so it's
been tough alot it is and sometimes I
didn't get to it until like late at
night after doing other things but it's
kind of stuck with it and usually if I
do just sit down and write jokes for an
hour even if 99% of them are not good I
do end up getting something out of it
that I like and so I think it pays off
that's like kind of something I learned
that like even if it doesn't feel
immediately like it's going well it's
still I think is worth doing and usually
by the end of it I feel super happy that
I did it and I have something to show
for it but but yeah for me yeah so a lot
of times I'll just sit down with a
notebook and just write jokes for an
hour or sometimes I'll use that time as
a combo of rewriting jokes that I had
before that like weren't really working
so I'll write it out until I'm like oh
here's the here's the version that makes
more sense and there were some times
while I'm doing it I'll be listening to
like sets that I did the day before that
I tried like jokes on line and writing
out rewriting those and things like that
so it's kind of a combination of things
but um but yeah I feel like writing by
hand for me at least works a lot in
terms of like first coming up with it
and then and then later I might type it
up and tweet some of them are things
like that but yeah I think yeah that's
something I would definitely recommend
to any comedian just trying to find the
time to do that because it's yeah it's
been super helpful to me and um and
everything so I think for anyone you
know it's definitely definitely worth
doing but but I know how yeah it's it
can definitely be intimidating I think
like oh that's so much time but I feel
like usually there's a time in the day
and especially now that we're all like
traveling less and stuff there's exactly
a good analogy to have very good
practice yeah I started like I realized
if I don't write in the morning that I
won't write so
I started this like right tink club here
on Facebook where every morning at 10:00
a.m. I get on Facebook live and I'll
just write for 10 minutes and people are
starting to tune in that are also
wanting to like start their own writing
routine and it's like 10 minutes out of
24 hours you know it's like a small
attainable goal like dinner dinners just
commented with like you know set low
expectations and celebrate when you
exceed those expectations it's like if
you can write 10 minutes cool check it
off the list sometimes it grows into 20
40 an hour sometimes but as long as I
write for 10 minutes at this point I'll
check it off the list and it doesn't
even have to be joke writing
I'll journal sometimes I'll just
brainstorm it's not every day I'm
sitting down trying to like reinvent
comedy or create the next big wave you
know like you mentioned having the minds
or like that thought that I'm not doing
enough I should be doing more and I feel
like every comedian goes through that
and I think having these small victories
throughout your day help you to kind of
quell that self-doubt behind well I
should be doing more yeah and so did X Y
& Z you know yeah exactly yeah that's
something I'm that still I still have to
constantly remind myself is to like yeah
celebrate those moments because
otherwise you know if I'm not enjoying
it I might be less likely to keep it up
but you mentioned writing in the morning
which i think is also super helpful so
yeah actually in addition to the joke
right I do try to actually journal like
three pages in the morning which is
something I heard in the artists way and
yeah I read that book a couple of times
it's highly recommended to basically I
think of anyone whatever your child is
but but you had the two main things I
got out of it where yeah writing three
pages of stream-of-consciousness in the
morning just to like clear your head and
that kind of thing and then also doing
something they call an artist date each
week which is like just doing something
for fun for yourself by yourself and
just enjoying like well now it's hard to
do some of those stuff because some of
it was like going to a museum or things
like that right
maybe goat spend some time in a park or
play an instrument or do something just
like for fun and even though it's not
technically working a lot of times that
actually makes you that's the stuff that
makes you feel inspired and actually
breeze a lot of new life into like once
you are back of work you feel kind of
refreshed or full of ideas
those are like two main things that have
definitely helped me a lot yeah I
haven't gotten through that book I've
read some of it but I've I've talked to
several people who found it super
helpful so that'll be a good resource
for listeners to find yeah yeah the
artists way is great I read it once by
myself and it was helpful but I found it
even more helpful the second time when I
read it every week I'd meet up with a
group of basically a lot of comedians
and other actors and stuff and we'd read
it the chapter together and I think
and then we'd check in without how we
felt like it was affecting us and debate
whether we agreed with stuff in it but I
think that because then you have like
the accountability of like okay now I I
can like I'm excited to not only do this
artist date but I feel like a positive
pressure and I'm excited to like tell
people about it and how it helped me or
but the and I think there's this other
book I read recently I would also I
think a lot filled with like called the
war of art yeah the war of art I've
heard of that okay that one's a quick
read and it's kind of a different angle
but super helpful in terms of he kind of
points out that like the hard part about
art or you know writing or anything that
you're trying to do creatively isn't
actually doing it but just getting
started so he's all about like
resistance is actually the enemy so a
lot of times when we have all these
nebulous things that were like oh I have
to worry about this and this is a kind
of all falls in the category of
resistance so if you're just training
yourself to a fight resistance each day
and like just to get started basically
getting started is the hardest part like
what we said so that's kind of his main
point but I feel like he says it pretty
concisely it's a quick read and I think
it's super helpful to to anyone just in
terms of like procrastinating lists and
stuff
yeah I think that accountability is huge
which is why I do the right 10 club just
because it is like a form of social
accountability and you mentioned at the
beginning of this they you mentioned you
actually going over jokes with comedians
like are you guys are online like just
spitballing jokes to each other what
does that look like I think more comics
could be doing that right now yeah
there's a small group of comedians where
we'll basically just each take turns and
run run a few jokes and a lot of it is
not necessarily even going into feedback
about it but just saying it to another
person in a small group has been super
helpful so yeah especially now that
there's not really any form of live
shows so things like that and also
running jokes I've done similar things
that are like Instagram live shows where
they're set up as a stand-up show so
it's a little weird sometimes just
saying your jokes and like maybe a bunch
of people are listening but you can only
see one person reacting is that but it's
it's still another way of things like
anything like that it has been helpful
to just actually it's keep telling jokes
with someone listening even if it's not
in the same room you can kind of still I
guess see at least one person's reaction
or a few people's reaction and like a
zoom chat or things like that so that's
and that's I think that's another thing
that's helped me write a lot because it
that I'm like oh there's I did it
yesterday now today they're doing it
again so it's like I want to write new
stuff so that it they're not just seeing
me say the same things so yeah that's
kind of online communities and then I've
been doing that with improv to you like
I did an improv practice with people and
like England yesterday and like then one
with people in like Idaho and stuff
because people are can kind of zoom like
use it from wherever so it's kind of
interesting that like do improv with
people that are like five hour time
difference across the ocean and stuff
but um but yeah I think having that book
that improv muscle in the state of
muscles like you know I use them a
little bit during this time that's been
super helpful so
I feel like I said Brenna just ask
around if I'm any things like that that
are available you know yeah a lot of a
lot I'm seeing a lot of comedians post
things like oh I missed the stage or all
this is getting boring or something but
it's like mmm I mean I feel like this is
for everyone but I think if we're gonna
keep it comedy centric it is just like
focus on what you can control how can
you make the most out of this
opportunity how can you make the most
out of your time and I think of very
like we're talking about you know
finding small victories to build upon I
think simply posting hey I'd like to get
a writing group together like you and I
are talking about right now on line to
pitch jokes and just start a social
accountability circle even if it's you
and just one other comic for the time
being and it organically grows from
there if it does it's just creating and
holding each other accountable instead
of us like kind of wallowing and we
think calm is still the most important I
mean look I'm like yo the world may be
ending but I gotta do this Skype Q&A
with Jacob because the comedians need to
know you know I mean we still think
comedy is like the most important thing
in the world but I think that's a good
thing for comics as I've been thinking
of different ways to be productive
during this and looking at how other
comedians are using their time wisely I
think that's a great one I haven't heard
is actually just having social
accountability groups where you spit
ball jokes and things like that mm-hmm
yeah and actually Lawrence says if if I
want to get writing done I set aside
proper free time for myself that day and
it stops me procrastinating because I
think I can do this but fee BuzzFeed
quiz later during my free time instead
of right now and I'm supposed to be
writing so she omits a carrot at the end
of the stick so she's like oh if I cross
this bridge of writing I get to like the
pot of gold on the other side or
something like that so that's
interesting yeah almost a reward system
in place so that's good
she actually also asked to what Jacob
what joke slash come back from wild and
out are you proudest of
um what Joker come back and my proudest
unwell no that's a good question yeah I
feel like I don't know um there's some
that yeah I don't know there's one with
Matt right that I feel like went pretty
well that I was happy with because I
kind of just came up with it in the
moment and it was something about like
he said I looked like Jared from Subway
and he's like really Matt was really
young at the time so I was like you look
like you got molested by Jared from
Subway which it was phrased differently
it was Oliver I'm in a rap battle but um
but I did think of that in the moment
which I it was like right when all of
the subway or scandal stuff was
happening now I don't know if that joke
is aged that well now that I think about
it but uh but basically at the time and
uh and I think maybe my first rap battle
that aired ever against Nick Cannon that
was kind of exciting to like actually be
in my first season and you know get to
basically like make fun of him to his
face
and I think it was something about how
like he was married to Mariah so he has
a lot of clout but does he ever get
lonely when she put some and time out um
were compared and everything but uh but
that was like that was a pretty fun
moment to think like he is the one that
got me on the show and yet he's like my
job is to make fun of him which is like
a lot of people don't get to make fun of
their boss in that way so to do it and
to actually get paid to do it and reward
it for those like it was pretty awesome
so yeah so just and I there were some
other fun moments on there but uh but in
general yeah it's just it's always a fun
job and we're yeah there's I think I'll
be on a couple episodes a season 15 and
then we're talking about shooting season
16 but obviously it's postponed for the
moment so hopefully we will get to do
that it's how many seasons have you been
on there well I did
yes I actually I did eight seasons I
have aired and then I actually did tape
some episodes on a ninth season so I've
performed on I guess nine different
seasons wow that's so cool man I yeah
they're really great about streamlining
everything and they can kind of film it
really quickly and it's kind of a sulli
all improvised so it's only takes a
couple hours to shoot and you unlike
other things you don't have to like
rehearse it a lot or add all of it okay
and so they can film like two or three a
day because you're kind of just trying
to make the most of the moment and then
you know they just edit it down to the
stuff that worked best but it's yeah
it's been pretty much a dream job I
guess so I'm so happy to have had the
host stand up and yeah hopefully I'm
hoping they both come back at some point
but yeah I was what would you what
percentage would you say is improvised
verse like written prepared material um
I'd say it's definitely almost all
improvised but there's definitely
moments where like if you're you know
you're gonna do like a rap battle and so
you can maybe like look at who's on the
other team and think like okay I can
start thinking of stuff and try to plan
it but then a lot of times it ends up
going in a different direction because
like they might say something crazy and
then you have to like try to talk that
so so I feel like my favorite stuff I've
done as always improvised but there's
some things right in like like if it's
like a funny pickup line game you can
sometimes think of that ahead of time or
things like that so it's kind of like
almost a mixed I feel like I've improv
and stand-up where you're kind of
writing on the fly but also like coming
up with stuff just literally on stage
and then trying to think of anything you
can but knowing that you might have to
totally change it and that kind of thing
yeah and it's so cool you're on there as
well you had such a fun flavor to the
show you know and that's why you been on
there so long is because it it plays
well with the chemistry of that show so
it's um it's cool it's cool you can
match all that high energy and you can
still like bring it to your level and
it's still
kills you know I mean that's just a
testament to like your comedic timing
and your self-awareness being in that
environment because I mean I've seen
tapings and I have done auditions for a
wild and out and like when you're in the
middle of it it's kind of like it can be
intimidating I mean there's a lot going
on you know we actually we have a we
have another good question here this is
from John Chapelle he asks who are you
Bell Chappell Chappell and he looks like
a white guy so I'm assuming he's not
related and it's spelled differently but
maybe maybe he's maybe that's his stage
name okay so it's to access this group
chat but thank you all just that's right
Oh in them in the Facebook group you're
saying oh I see okay I think I see it
now yeah it's in the Facebook group and
then I pull up I'm recording with
something called ECAM oh yeah yes so
it's like it's like a third party app
that I can live stream through and then
I can pull up people's comments onto the
screen and do like okay sound effects
like like the applause you like so much
at the beginning so okay this is great
no I see it now yeah that's awesome very
cool so yeah I've been I've been really
enjoying it I actually have an affiliate
link if anyone wants to get their owns
ECAM subscription I have an affiliate
link so you can support the jola verse
that's my venmo comedy show I'm pushing
ECAM live affiliate links I'll link it
in the show notes so John asks who are
Jacobs comedic influences and what
specials do you think are helpful to
learn body language okay so comedic
influences and specials that are helpful
to learn body language I mean some of my
favorite comedians I love
Mike Birbiglia I think he's got some
comedy that is surprisingly kind of
moving as like a emotional story as in
addition to being like funny with jokes
the whole time so like his albums like
um sleepwalk with me the album which is
like one of my favorites ever or my
girlfriend's boyfriend those are pretty
great I think in terms of also body
language he is able to like really
deliver and commit really hard to the
physicality of a lot of the jokes and
embodying characters but the writing and
storytelling is really strong and I
cried at the end of both of the cycle
which is like a pretty unusual for a
stand-up show to cry at most you know
you know you know be emotionally
invested like it you know to the degree
of like watching a Pixar movie or
something so yes I'd highly recommend
those especially at the sleepwalk with
me and my girlfriend's boyfriend
problems and/or I think the special of
my girlfriend's boyfriend is on Netflix
I don't think there's a special of the
other one but it's worth listening to
the album for sure and yeah I always
when I was starting out Demetri Martin
was kind of the first person I saw that
was doing lower energy stuff that was it
kind of made me realize like because I
was kind of shy and quiet growing up I
didn't realize that you could kind of be
yourself on stage and you didn't it
wasn't a job exclusively for people that
were naturally super loud or aggressive
or confident so that was kind of what
first got me thinking like maybe I
should try this out when I saw a Jimi
tree Martin I think on his first like
conan appearance when I was in high
school
and so but there's so many great
specials and comedians now so I mean
yeah it's hard to keep track but I love
the new specials I've seen from like
Michelle will Amy shoe killer yeah yeah
Nikki Glaser's great and yeah I mean I
love Tom Segura and he's super nice as
well which you know is awesome and let
me think
where I meet him Tom yeah I years ago I
I featured for him at this amazing club
in Madison Wisconsin and yeah he was
just super funny and super nice like
super funny on stage but super nice and
funny offstage like like there were
things that were happening to him in
real time with like like weird
interactions with fans from the audience
that would happen and then he'd just
tell us about it in the greenroom
immediately afterwards and it already
sounded like as funny as like a worked
out stand-up bit but he was just he just
has this like great perspective and the
way he describes things and or maybe
experiences the world like he's just
able to like portray that and such a
like funny and engaging way so and and
he's he was also just yeah super nice to
be and all the other comics like I ran
into him years after that like festivals
and stuff and he's obviously at that
point where it was like there's no
reason for him to talk to me but he was
like oh no you're like he was like
giving me all these compliments on stuff
I was doing I'm like I don't even know
why you're aware that like you have so
much other stuff come on well he's a
really good guy
and super hilarious on and off stage but
but yeah there's a lot of great special
I just watched Ronny Chang special was
amazing and I've been trying to watch as
many as I can
there's so many great ones I'm sure I
haven't even gotten to yet but uh yeah I
mean I like I always like bill birnes
comedy because you know he's able to
pull off so many like edgy angles in a
way that I did I've never you know come
that close to I have most of my stuff is
pretty safe and cleans but it's like
it's so inspiring to watch someone do
that kind of thing where he like didn't
take those chances and yet end up
actually coming from a good place but
being able to risk those kind of like
tricky premises is really impressive you
exactly
yeah the Ronny Chang one's great I just
watched that one a few days ago it's
very good and it is a good one of like
an example of like commit
- a bit like he really commits to a bit
it's do you see him out and about in the
New York scene like working out stuff
yeah yeah I saw him recently before all
the stuff happened at New York Comedy
Club and just doing brand new like
killer stuff and yeah his physicality
and just like the writing is so good and
the jokes already but the fact that he
can like heighten it so much and keep
like topping it with more and more like
like you know like a lot of the first
lines of his jokes is like what if I had
that I would just tell it and then move
on and it probably wouldn't sell but he
like sells that really hard but then he
was like tops that with like an even
better punchline and the way he like
acts things out physically and adds new
jokes just from that oh it says like
super impressive so yeah he's so much
fun to watch I only met him maybe once
or twice briefly so I don't really know
him but just from watching him around
town yeah he's always crushes it is he's
one of the best comedians I think right
now for sure you said that Mike
Birbiglia and Demetri Martin were like
at the top of at the top of your list
have you got to work with them or meet
them um yeah I think I've met them both
briefly like a long time ago and yeah at
the time that I met four Bigley I was
like so obsessed with his albums and
stuff that it was like I almost didn't
think he was a real person and I was
super intimidated more so than like
anyone else I've met that was like if I
met other famous people and stuff I
think just cuz I heard his album so much
so yeah so it's been fun to watch him
even now he's doing like some fun
Instagram live videos and things doing
fundraising for comedy club waitstaff
which is really good so so yeah and then
I think I went to Dmitry mines show
years ago and he signed a book that I
bought of hism is nice and everything so
it's been kind of cool to like get to
see those kind of people live oh yeah
some other specials I just thought of
recently I mean I look like samurai was
news special on YouTube and
yeah okay one things was great on
Netflix phone adop but yeah so I'm sure
when I met privet it was I'm sure I was
super awkward but I'm glad I got to say
hi and everything and I've definitely
still a big fan and yeah I'm so happy
there's just so many great comedians out
there now because it makes me feel
always like I have to like step my game
up and try to get better there's always
like so many good people right now
exactly yeah and even in talking about
the actual comedic process
Trent has a good question here about
your personal evolution of comedy and
did you Trent asked Trent Bab ass did
you go through different voice
fluctuations on your comedy journey
different tones of delivering a
punchline accenting the last word
deadpan tone goes up etc that's a good
question I mean for me it's funny
because a lot of people think that I
don't have any tone change at any time
on stage or in my real life and I guess
I do tend to like sound kind of like I
have a monotone at all times but it's
funny because uh yeah I do try to work
on that and I think that stuff does make
a huge difference and sometimes with
more you know some people it's more
clear they're like super high-energy and
they're really selling a joke but but
yeah like for me on stand-up or wild not
or something I've found that like a lot
of jokes more what they don't work
unless you you yeah you have to really
deliver them a certain way so you I
think it is important to find those
moments of like even if it is more
subtle like what I the way I do it
you know I'd love to commit even more
way more but um but yeah I think even at
this you know if you are kind of telling
things and not a lot of range like I do
it is still yeah I definitely think
about that stuff a lot and it's so super
important and can make or break a set
and so even though if someone else might
be like oh that's not good like am I
like it still is gonna pop if you say it
a certain way and it's not if you say it
differently so yeah it's you definitely
have to like emphasize certain words
sometimes or pauses and stuff I think I
have like falling backs
sometimes I'm like trying to like focus
a lot on the writing and sometimes that
can make it easier to get away with
certain jokes without selling them but
at the same time I've been pushing
myself lately to like remember to really
be in the moment and figure out how to
sell it in my own way even if it's Matt
you know the biggest act out or
something that someone else might be
able to do so I think like doing improv
where I sometimes do try it more like
emotional stuff for characters has
helped a lot so so yeah I definitely try
to like bring that into my standup but
but yeah I'm probably way behind in that
delivery department and a lot of people
but in my own way I do yeah I think it's
so important to think about that stuff
and just try to figure out how to sell
the joke but also be genuine to yourself
and how you do it you know so you will
maybe when you're approaching a
punchline when you say the punchline you
may say the punchline with a different
tone or a different volume as opposed to
the rest of the joke yeah I think
depending on the joke I think a lot of
times I might not necessarily change
much up but but yeah I do try to like
maybe emphasize that that was the joke
or if a joke if so like some of my jokes
might be a little more corny or
something so then I might try to make it
clear like I'm saying in it may be an
overly jokey way just to make it clear
that I'm aware that it's like a silly
joke or something
whereas I do a lot of times I do still
do like deadpan and stuff which can work
too but that can be tricky with certain
audiences if they've missed the joke
because then it's like oh they might
have like just maybe because I didn't
change my voice they like didn't
recognize that that was a punchline
because it was
kind of - sometimes I've written stuff
that's like maybe too subtler - you know
overcomplicate or whatever so yes I I
don't know yeah I feel like it's
important to just yeah I find a delivery
that works and everything without it
seeming you know without it being forced
but yeah it's a lot of just tracking
error and trying different things and
saying it how you would say it to a
friend if you are trying to make them
laugh and that's just a lot of testing
out different things and seeing what
feels right you know exactly yeah I like
how you said trial and error and then
it's like saying something that you
would say to a friend that's funny and
translating it to a live audience and
that's the difficult I mean that is the
difficult part and I remember hearing
Jerry Seinfeld say maybe for like the
first 10 years his comedy was just like
from like his nose to his chin there was
no physicality the delivery wasn't
really honed in like I mean that was for
me personally I'm just now I'm 10 years
in and I'm just now like okay how can I
incorporate more physicality or I'm
becoming a little more intentional about
it but for the longest time I was really
all about the writing and especially
early on and starting out in comedy I
think the writing will help you like you
said get away with a lot more than if
you're just trying to deliver it a
certain way I think starting with
writing first is a great foundation that
then you can start to build on and a lot
of your delivery develops from just
being on stage a lot and just just
saying the jokes over and over again and
those natural inflections and those
natural tones and physicalities will
start to kind of organically grow out of
the confidence you have in those words
you're saying yeah for sure yeah I think
stage time is super important and like
you said just a lot of trying it out and
yeah I mean sometimes I will say
something in conversation that gets a
lot but is
I'm able to maybe get it to work on
stage later because it came from a
genuine place so I think it's kind of
yeah that's I think that's always good
to recreate like because when you're
trying to make friends laughs you're not
really trying it's just like fun so
there you can find ways to channel that
type of part that's genuine to you on
stage I think that's helpful
yep yeah you mentioned Seinfeld I saw
him recently a couple of months ago at
the Beacon and so yeah I was cool to see
him how much now he does like
physicality and using this huge theater
where he's like running around the stage
and acting things out and so yeah it's
awesome to see like how much how many
levels he has at this point obviously
he's doing very well everyone knows but
uh but yeah it's a little bit yeah
action dude that's great
all right we just have just one more
here Oh Lawrence said it's dinner time
in the UK so I have to go we'll watch
the rest back after oh cool yeah man
we've had viewers like from India
Ireland Canada like yep people all over
the world are watching this so this is
great so let's see the final okay this
this is actually from the same person so
maybe we can kind of combine them but
Dennis Tooley asks you mentioned having
a pretty clean set how important do you
think it is to be able to work clean and
he actually hooked owns a comedy club in
a Greenwood Indiana called guddi's I I
was actually awesome up there headlining
last year pre quarantine and that their
whole brand is like clean
family-friendly club so from your
experience being a comedy did you say 12
years yeah I guess twelve and a half
it'll be like 13 and and this September
so yeah maybe like 12 in that I think
that's right I think that's very much
yeah so how important do you think it is
to be able to work clean um that's a
good question yeah I think yeah working
being super helpful especially and
getting just getting to do more shows
and getting to do a lot of awesome shows
and so I mean I was exclusively clean
for a long time I started out just
because I would do these like my first a
lot of my first headlining shows were
like in my hometown and so my whole
family would be there so it wasn't
anything anyone else imposed on me but
just in my own mind I was like okay I
don't want to like talk about certain
things in front of like literally all my
grandparents and my parents would be
there and stuff so now I do have some
stuff that's not clean but I still have
a ton of clean stuff and definitely over
an hour of clean stuff so I think that
ended up working in my favor a lot and
especially later on just I know comedy
is all about I think it is important
also to express yourself and be genuine
but in terms of just financially to have
clean stuff can really pay off in the
long run if you find you know especially
if you find if it's something you
gravitate towards and enjoy it because
yeah as much as like I don't want to
tell anyone just censor themselves but
but if the more clean stuff you have you
know later on there's a lot of colleges
expect that and they pay well and then
even on Sirius XM I've heard like
there's such fewer so many fewer tracks
available for the clean channel so the
the comedian's have like fully clean
albums or even a few clean tracks can
make so much money on there because they
play it so many times whereas on a
channel where it's explicit there are
you know it's just kind of undone dated
with so many more that it's just harder
to get as much air time and that's you
get paid each time that happens from
what I've heard I'm still waiting for my
album to come out and down the road but
um but yeah so kind of at every level
um you know there's fun Church shows
there's fun College as corporate shows
and in the past cruises I don't know if
that'll still happen but there's a lot
of opportunities where they expect you
to be queen so yeah I wouldn't say to
necessarily sincere is often in in
general and writing
anything but but if you can do at least
have in your arsenal a lot of clean
stuff and have the ability yeah so be
queen for a long set when needed then
it's great to have that and just though
I don't you'll have a lot more
opportunities you know yeah and I like
how you said it's like if it is if it
comes naturally to you I mean if it's
something you authentically are
gravitating towards then by all means
follow that you know for me like I I
when I started comedy I set the bar that
I wanted to be clean just so I could
entertain as many people as possible and
I'm in your belief system that I don't
tell people what they should or
shouldn't do I like we all sing a
different song up there and I I like
that everyone has the freedom to do that
and I don't really care what someone
else does as long as it's funny you know
but for me I knew that I would be able
to entertain more people and I have
found 10 years into this I have booked a
lot more work just from being clean a
performant random Golf Club outings you
know it like country clubs and people's
birthday parties and hosting like
corporate awards shows and a lot of that
work and like you said colleges and a
lot of that work the number one criteria
a lot of the time is are you clean or
not I mean that's yeah that's really
like that really gets you in the door at
a lot of places but even like you said
even if you're not completely clean
having the ability to go clean will
really open up some doors for you yeah
okay mm-hmm so let and the final one
this is actually from Dennis too and he
said if the quarantine life is the new
normal hold on let me throw this on the
screen that's always a fun effect if the
quarantine life is the new normal what
three things will you focus on in order
to get your comedy fix yeah that's a
good question
it's something weird to have all these
various avenues of live shows out of the
picture but I think the three things I'd
focus
and I guess I'd have to say it like the
writing an hour it is been super helpful
so yeah I think writing everyday and
also just putting things out there
online in any way you can like over
Skype like this or over zoom or whatever
it is just any way that you can keep
telling your jokes to other person so
you have that muscle because that's kind
of the equivalent right now if stage
time and writing which are the two
important things so yeah and just always
kind of I think going out of your
comfort zone as well in terms of finding
new things to do just because it is such
an unusual situation and it might last a
long time so finding out how you can you
know do shows in new ways or try new
things with sketches or podcasts or
whatever it is so I think those are like
kind of the main things you say you're
in writing everyday what was the second
one you said um yeah I guess performing
as much as possible online possible in
however you can and then anything out of
your comfort zone like maybe trying to
start a podcast or do more sketches and
things like that
yeah and yeah yeah and that kind of
varies per person but yeah whatever kind
of new types of comedy you haven't tried
yet it's a good time to try them all oh
man that is great yeah great advice
there um are you in New York still by
the way
yeah I'm still in New York my man we
miss you I hope your SATA there man are
you just like cooped up in an apartment
right now yeah I've kind of just been
staying in my apartment a lot and so
yeah it'll be interesting to see how
this all turns out um I don't know
well we're here for you at the hot
breath averse Jacob if you ever need
anything
awesome you know feel free to hang out
and we're we did this live Q&A in this
comedy group if you ever feel like
interacting with other comics you know
there's right now we're at almost 400
and it's like people comics from around
the world we're on
every continent but Antarctica so far so
it's it's been very cool to get to do
these live Q&A s with comedians of your
caliber so we really do appreciate your
time
oh yeah fun things for me always you
know is a little is that is there
anything else you want the world to know
before we get out of here um not much
yeah I guess if people want to stay in
touch they can find me on Instagram and
Twitter at Mr Jenkins and I'll be
posting a lot of like new jokes and
things like that and if I do any more
like you know streamed shows / zoom or
something I'll post about that on there
and if you go to my website you won't
see any tour dates right now but that's
Jacob Williams call me doc and and so
yeah if they follow me on there also
announced once I'm putting out like a
special and album and everything like
that so I'm excited to hopefully do that
soon love it man love it yeah well
whenever that album and special comes
out please let us know here and we will
help you promote however we can man
we're big fans here
likewise thanks yeah as always always a
good time all right well thank you Jacob
stay safe out there buddy
are you - thanks Joel how's it going